mais tout d'abord le voyage de François
mitteran en Amérique latine première
étape le Venezuela le chef de l'État
doit notamment évoquer la dette
extérieure du pays en vue d'alléger la
créance à noter le léger malaise du chef
de l'État son arrivée à Caracas coup de
fatigue sans conséquence puisque le
programme aussi officiel a repris dès ce
soir correspondance de notre envoyé
spécial au Venezuela mon
Terman une demi-heure environ après son
arrivée à Caracas alors qu'il avait déjà
répondu au discours de bienvenue le
président de la République trèsp a fait
un réel malaise on l'a vu faire un signe
à son aide de camp un signe à son épouse
également pour qu'on lui apporte un
siège les autorités du Venezuela
visiblement étaient très embarrassé et
ne savaient pas comment réagir
l'entourage du président de la
République également a été réellement
paniqué tout cela a duré 3 4 minutes et
puis le président de la République a
continué la cérémonie en serrant à
nouveau des mains et son programme s'est
poursuivi comme prévu ces VoyaG comp
essentiellement de dossiers d'abord
celui de l'endettement du vzuela qui
entend jouer un rôle actif dans la
gestion de ce problème ensuite la drogue
le Venezuela est voisin de la Colombie
il devientonête de P pour l'exportation
de la cocaïne vers l'Europe c'est l'Ance
du rglement de C question c'est un long
processus qui
commenceac